je pensais que seulement mon bébé à y
porter des couches et bien non j'ai moi
même porter des couches ce genre ce
genre de couches qui en réalité sont des
couches pour lutter contre
l'incontinence
parce que justement on a pas on n'a pas
nécessairement des produits spécifiques
qui sont adaptés à la période post
partum
on n'est pas au courant qu'on pousse et
nié pendant des semaines et de
saignements extrêmement abondante pour
certaines femmes moi j'ai tellement
c'est nier que parfois j'avais
l'impression de nous faire pipi dessus
tellement c'était conséquent comme comme
comme quantité de liquide
[Musique]
et
le post partum c'est une période où le
corps est enflée le corps saigne le
corps à mal c'est une convalescence
c'est un moment en fait pendant au moins
six semaines où le corps va se remettre
d'une épisode traumatique pour lui c'est
pas anodin dans une grosse de neuf mois
c'est pas anodin à l'accouchement et la
période qui vient après est loin d'être
anodine également ce qui va en réalité
extrêmement choquée également c'est que
ma mère ne m'en ait pas parlé c'est que
mes amis qui était déjà maman ne m'en
ait pas parlé et c'est qu'en réalité et
la société dans son ensemble cherche à
garder le secret autour de ça au cours
de cette période là comme si c'était
honteux comme si on ne voulait pas faire
peur cette peur incroyable il ya des
réactions
arrêtez vous allez en voir une baisse de
la natalité les femmes ne vont plus
vouloir avoir d'enfant non on n'est pas
là pour faire peur ce hashtag il est là
pour informer pour expliquer que c'est
une réalité il faut être préparé pour le
vivre plus sereinement
et pour éviter justement c'est ses
nombreux nombreux nombreux cas y'a plus
rien autour de 15% des femmes qui font
des dépressions post partum
et c'est aussi lié à ça à ce manque
d'information ce manque de préparation
autre élément qui m'a énormément choqué
et sur lequel j'aurai aimé être préparé
c'est le phénomène des contractions post
accouchement
les contractions peuvent être
extrêmement douloureuse ce qui a été mon
cas donc des réalités qui sont très
commune très très commune les
contractions après un accouchement c'est
le fait en fait de l'utérus qui vient se
contracter contracté contracté pour
retrouver sa taille initiale et en
parlant de ce fameux d'utérus
quand on sort dans l'accouchement dans
l'est dans les films dans les séries
dans l'inconscient collectif par rapport
aux représentations qu'on a de la femme
enceinte et de la maternité
on sort de la maternité et hop le
montrer tout plat voilà
un bébé de 3 4 kg une fois qu'il est
sorti on retrouve son corps son corps
initial hors l'utérus est un organe qui
passe de la taille d'une figue à la
taille d'une pastèque quand il l'a
contient à votre bébé va se rétracter
petit à petit ça peut prendre des
semaines ça de prendre des mois ce
pantalon qui fait partie d'une série de
pantalons et de jean que j'avais acheté
pour ma grossesse et sans feu des
pantalons lambda auquel on ajoute une
une bande de tissu élastique qui peuvent
donc du coup le pantalon soutient le
ventre et empêche une pression dessus
comme son nom l'indiqué je pensais que
ce pantalon je ne porterais que durant
ma grossesse
or un élément qui n'est pas tout à fait
communiquer et qui n'est pas représenté
dans la culture populaire c'est le fait
qu'une jeune femme une femme une jeune
femme qui sort de la maternité avec son
nouveau né est le ventre encore
extrêmement enfler c'est à peu près
l'équivalent d'un ventre d'une grossesse
de 4 5 mois et pour l'estimé de soi
c'est assez difficile à gérer lorsqu'on
n'a pas été exposés à ce genre d'image
si on prend par exemple une kate
middleton qui sort présenter son bébé
avec un ventre plat avec quelque chose
qui va cacher sous la rondeur de son
ventre parce que son utérus n'est pas
encore remis en place
ça va mettre des pressions sur sur les
nouvellement construit un maton comment
elle va avoir un ventre plat leur voix
comme chantal maternité j'ai encore un
ventre énorme chose qui est tout à fait
normal il faut normaliser ce corps là ce
corps post partum les femmes finissent
en fait isolé démunis face à ces
douleurs
face à leur nouveau physique face à une
période qui est une encore une fois une
convalescence
ça n'arrive pas tout le monde attention
à ces des symptômes qui peuvent toucher
de façon aléatoire mais ce sont des
choses qui sont quand même assez commune
et qu'il faut savoir la femme dans cette
période-là est dans une phase ex
d'extrême vulnérabilité extrême
vulnérabilité physique psychique et elle
a besoin de tout le soutien du monde
elle a besoin du soutien de son
entourage de ses amis de son époux et
pour avoir le soutien de son époux il
faut que après cette prise de parole
importante qu'on observe
enduit sur les réseaux il faut passer à
l'action politique et l'action publique
et un congé paternité conséquent qu'ils
ne soient pas anecdotique on a besoin
d'un congé paternité qui soit de
plusieurs mois il faut que le père soit
là avec la mer pour d'abord loué nouer
des liens avec son enfant comme la maman
et bien sûr les dé la mère quand elle
sort d'un accouchement
on doit prendre soin d'elle autant
qu'elle doit prendre soin du bébé aucun
le parent doit prendre soin du bébé
[Musique]